Oh, I have to press to move forward. I think I got so excited by dual targeting that I read my
assignment for what I was supposed to prepare. And after dual targeting, I didn't read the whole
assignment. So prepare the slide three times. I prepared this PowerPoint three times. And I think
I got it right in the end, ultimately. So we'll talk about a rationale, merging data, and the
dual CAR-T strategies that many of my colleagues will be going in depth. Okay. So I think you can't
make a case for dual targeting agents in myeloma, especially for CAR-T or whether even bispecifics,
without talking about the resistance mechanisms that get us to that point. So far, the first of
the, you know, therapies approved in the TCRT space are mostly BCMA-targeted. And we've seen
biallelic deletions, missense mutations, and then obviously the soluble BCMA decoy shedding
as such.
Some of the mechanism, mechanistic reasons as to why we have relapsed after a single targeting
CAR-T or a bispecific. And we know that there's evidence for that because ultimately, despite
having the five-year data that I presented yesterday for CAR-T2-1, we still have plenty
of patients that ultimately relapse. And this is some of the studies done by, mostly led by
Nizar Balas and his group that have shed insight into how we arrive to the, you know, the, you know,
to mutations and ultimately resistant mechanisms to BCMA-targeted agents and even GPR-C.
So I think the rationale for dual antigen targeting has to do with the tumor heterogeneity that
antigens are expressed in, you know, at different levels. You may have double positive, single
positive BCMA cells. You may have single positive GPR-C5D tumor cells. So when you have dual
antigen, you will have no escape route to the antigen target. And so, you know, there's a lot of
evidence for that. And I think that the rationale for dual antigen targeting has to do with the tumor
heterogeneity that antigens are expressed in, you know, at different levels. You may have double positive,
single positive BCMA cells. You may have single positive GPR-C5D tumor cells. So when you have dual
positive BCMA cells. You may have dual positive GPR-C5D tumor cells. So when you have dual
positive GPR-C5D tumor cells. You may have dual positive GPR-C5D tumor cells. So when you have dual
CMA and GPRC-D5D, by specific, tri-specific, we saw improved rates of oral toxicities in comparison
to their single agent, single antigen targeting, such as talquitamab. So, there's three structural
approaches to consider CAR-T. One is your CAR-POOL mechanism, where you have two different
single antigen CAR-T products that are infused together, and we've seen evidence, Dr. Garfield
has done some of this work. We see tandem CAR-T, which is, you have a single T-cell that
expresses one CAR-T construct with two antigen-binding domains, and that's going to be presented by
the AZ product later on, as well as the BCMA-GPRC-5D tandem constructs. And then you obviously have
the dual CAR-T, and that single T-cell co-expresses two fully separate CARs via bisastronic or
single antigen-binding domains, and that's going to be presented by the AZ product later on, as well as the BCMA-GPRC-5D.
Right now, the space in this, the space is getting very crowded. I use CLAW to generate the slides, so if there's an error, I apologize, but there's 305 total CAR-T trials in myeloma, 65 are dual or multi-targeting trials, that's about 21%, and BCMA-CD19 seems to be the most common pair, but you can see on the image on the right that we have multiple combinations, whether it's BCMA-CD19, BCMA-GPRC-5D, SLAM-F7 in combination with BCMA, BCMA-GPRC-5D, and BCMA-GPRC-5D.
And so on and so forth, and even there's a tri-specific or tri-specific CAR-T in development as well. And some of the active dual CAR-T clinical trials, we've seen some of the evidence generated from China in the relapse refractory settings, which will be presented more in detail, and now we have DURGA-1 in the relapse refractory setting that's ongoing over here, as well as the newly diagnosed studies, similarly with BCMA-GPRC-5D.
And you can see some efficacy that we see overall response rates close to 90% to even 100% when it's done in the newly diagnosed setting. I don't have the slide over here, but actually you do see it, the CRS grade 3 is almost 0% and neurotoxicity is limited. So I think the combination of BCMA-CD19 is unique. It may be that CD19 is expressed at low levels, but detectable. I'm not sure if that's possible.
And the manufacturing of this platform is 22 to 36 hours, so that may, by the time we get the product, it may be within two weeks, alleviating a lot of the issues that we're dealing with patients right now. And some of the efficacy data you see when we combine BCMA with GPRC with overall response rates ranging from 78 to 86, depending on which methodology of CAR-T construct was used in these trials.
I'll go forward.
So I think the biggest question is where does CAR-T fit? Where does dual CAR-T fit? I think the strongest case for dual targeting is in high-risk and EMD.
Because CiltaCell has, and its counterparts, and even AnitoCell, I think, are generating enough evidence that we are getting our dues for the single CAR-T construct investment. But I think we struggle still in high-risk and extramedullary disease.
I think newly diagnosed.
There's multiple myeloma where the bar is much higher, right? We're not going to, I think, a treatment-related mortality of 9% or 10% in Parkinsonian risk.
It's hard to swallow and take that on when we're doing CAR-T studies in first line or that becoming standard of care. So I think it's, there's an unmet need in that area to generate or provide the safest and the most effective CAR-T.
So I think that's it.
That's the most exciting opportunity. And then I know that the trials that are ongoing right now, there is post-BCMA CAR-T salvage, and there is some efficacy that these dual CAR-Ts can work over there as well.
And obviously beyond dual targeting, we have now, there's preclinical data for GPRC, BCMA, and CD38, which are all highly and independently expressed in malignant plasma cells. So there's, you have triple antigen coverage. There is, you know, enhanced JAK stat signaling.
So we will see how that pans out actually in the end. I think I've already specified, have about three seconds that, you know, single antigen targeting drives rapid clonal selection. Dual antigen targeting eliminates both single positive and double positive myeloma cells. It addresses the heterogeneous target expression in myeloma, and it prevents single antigen negative escape and ultimately may increase in tumor specificity and improve toxicity profile. And that's it.
My conclusions are structural approaches all have distinct biology, logistics, and cost trade-offs. And we are going to hear more about the dual targeting approaches that are already currently in development. On that note, thank you.